All right, we're
on problem 44.
And they said, which is the
factored form of 3a squared
minus 24ab plus 48b squared?
And if this confuses you with
a's and b's instead of an x
there, I just like to think of
in this case, this looks like
an x squared.
So I like to think of it the
same way I would think of it
in terms of if this was an x
squared minus some number
times x plus some
other number.
So let's put that in the
back of your head.
If that's confuses you,
don't worry about it.
But the first thing I like to
do is try to get rid of the
coefficient on the, in this
case, the a squared term.
Let's see if we can factor
out a number.
Well, sure.
All of these are
divisible by 3.
3 is divisible by 3, 24 is
divisible by 3 and 48 is
divisible by 3.
So we should be able to factor
out a 3, so let's do that.
So that is equal to 3 times
a squared minus 8ab.
24 divided by 3 is
8 and there's a
minus in front of it.
Plus 48 divided by-- 3.
My brain was getting
ahead of me.
48 divided by 3 is
16b squared.
Now to factor this we have to
think about it as, are there
two numbers-- well,
think of it.
Let me rewrite this
a little bit.
If we view a as kind of the
independent variable-- you
wouldn't have to do it, but I
just wanted you to visualize
it properly.
3a squared minus 8b times
a plus 16b squared.
So if we viewed a squared as
kind of the independent
variable or the x term, so now
this kind of has the shape of
polynomials that hopefully
you're used to factoring a
little bit.
We just have to think, OK, are
there two numbers that add up
to minus 8b, and that when I
multiply the two numbers, I
get 16b squared?
So first all, the number
is going to be
in terms of b, obviously.
Because if I'm adding them and
I get a b and-- I get b's.
And if I square them
I get a b squared.
And it also makes me lead to
it's the same number, just
used twice.
Otherwise, it would be weird
to get a squared here.
So the number that should pop
out, you say, OK, what two
numbers add up to minus 8
and that when I square
it is equal to 16?
Minus 4, right?
Minus 4, minus 4 is minus 8.
Minus 4 squared is 16.
So the number we're talking
about is minus 4b, right?
Minus 4b.
b, that's a b.
Plus minus 4b is equal
to minus 8b.
And minus 4b squared is
equal to 16b squared.
So we can factor this out to be
3-- let me switch colors.
3 times.
We said minus 4b
is the number.
When you add it twice
you get minus 8b.
And you square it,
you get that.
So it's a minus 4b
times a minus 4b.
And that is choice C.
Next problem, 40--
did I skip 45?
I did.
Let me copy and paste
45 in here.
Can't
skip problems. 45.
Copy and paste it in.
OK.
Maybe over do on top
of this one.
Let me see if I can
erase this.
Look at that.
All right, now I can paste
45 and we're ready to go.
Which is a factor of x squared
minus 11x plus 24?
So there's two ways to do it.
You could just factor this.
Well, that's the easiest way.
Or you could test for 0's.
But we'll just factor.
So if we wanted to say-- well,
let me just-- x squared minus
11x plus 24.
So just like the last problem
you have to say, what two
numbers when I add them equal
to minus 11, and when I
multiply them, is equal
to positive 24?
So first of all, if I'm
multiplying them and I get a
positive 24, they're either
both positive or
they're both negative.
Since this is a negative number
it tells me that they
both have-- I mean they both
can't be positive.
You can't add two positive
numbers and
end up with a negative.
So we're going to deal with
two negative numbers.
So essentially, what two
negative numbers when I add
them equals minus 11 and when I
multiplying them equals 24?
And hopefully, 8 and
3 pop out at you.
Because minus 8 plus minus
3 is equal to minus 11.
That's that.
And then minus 8 times minus
3 is positive 24.
So this can be factored as x
minus 8 times x minus 3.
And if we look at their
choices, they
had x minus 3 there.
And of course, don't
get this confused.
If they said, solve this
equation, right?
This is just an expression.
Now it becomes an equation
if we put an equal sign.
Then we would have this equaling
0 and then you could
say the roots of this polynomial
or the solutions to
the equation are what
makes this true.
And then the solutions
wouldn't be
minus 8 and minus 3.
The solutions would be
what makes this 0.
So it's be x is equal to 8 would
make this 0, or x is
equal to 3 would make that 0.
But anyway, I'm going off on a
tangent and that's not what
they asked you.
But I think that confuses
people sometimes.
OK, 46.
Which of the following shows
9t squared plus 12t plus 4
factored completely?
OK, now this is an interesting
one because immediately, when
I look at the numbers, there's
not one number that I can just
factor out of everything.
9, 12, and 4, they don't have
any common factors, so I can't
just do that simplification.
So we're going to do a little
bit more complexity.
But the best way to think about
is whatever's on the t
squared, this is probably kind
of-- this whole expression, if
we're trying to factor it into
two binomials or into one
binomial, this is going to
be the first term of that
binomial squared.
So we're going to be dealing
with something like 3t.
I'm just taking the square
root of 9t squared.
3t plus some number.
Let's say plus a.
Times 3t plus b.
And now we can actually
just multiply this out
and see what happens.
Well first of all, they gave
us a multiple choice.
We could just multiply these
out and see what happens.
But let's pretend like that they
didn't give us choices
and we had to do this
in a vacuum.
If we did this in a vacuum,
we would have
to factor it ourselves.
We wouldn't just be able
to test their choices.
Let's do that.
So if we multiply this
out, we have 3t
times 3t is 9t squared.
Then you 3t times b,
so it's plus 3bt.
Plus 3at plus ab.
So this simplifies to
9t squared plus.
Now what are we adding?
Let's see.
It says 3 times, a plus b, t.
So it'd be 3 times,
a plus b, t.
I just added these two terms and
I factored out the t and
the 3 plus ab.
Well now we can do a little
pattern matching, right?
We could say a plus b times
3 is equal to 12.
So a plus b is equal to what?
a plus b is equal to 12.
This whole coefficient right
here is a 12 up here.
So a plus b, it must
be equal to 4.
Because 4 times 3 is equal to
12. a plus b is equal to 4 and
we have a times b is
also equal to 4.
So the only number that I can
think of when I add them I get
4, when I multiply them
I get 4 is 2 and 2.
Both of these are 2.
So if I were to factor this
completely I get 3t plus 2
squared, essentially.
Because both of these terms
are the same thing, and
that's choice A.
A faster way frankly, to do this
might have just been to
multiply this out and say,
that's the same thing.
Anyway, next problem.
What is the complete
factorization
of 32 minus 8z squared?
So let's think about
this a little bit.
So the first thing that I like
to do once again is to try to
factor out any numbers that are
just common to all of the
terms. So let me do that.
So 32 minus 8z squared.
8 goes into both of
these, right?
So let's factor out an 8.
And actually, let's factor out
a negative 8, and I'll show
you why did that.
Because I like to put the
z squared, I like
that one to be positive.
So let's factor out
a negative 8.
And so you get a minus 8.
And you didn't have
to do that.
You could have just
factored an 8.
What's 32 divided by minus 8?
That's minus 4.
And then minus 8z squared
divided by minus 8 is just
plus z squared.
And so we can rearrange this, so
this becomes minus 8, times
z squared minus 4.
And now I'll review this because
this is an Algebra 1
test, so maybe this isn't
obvious to you.
But in general, if you see
something like this, a plus b
times a minus b-- and this might
be a good exercise for
you to multiply this out.
But this is equal to a squared
minus b squared, because the
middle terms cancel out.
And that's a good exercise
for you to do.
So this has that
same property.
This is a squared
minus b squared.
This is a perfect square.
So then this up here can be
factored as minus 8 times--
this is a squared
minus b squared.
So if we could say a
is z and b is 2.
Because then when we would
have z squared minus 2
squared, which is 4.
So if a is z, so it's z plus
2 times z minus 2.
This is probably the most common
thing you'll see in a
lot of factoring examples.
You'll see something that has
this pattern, a squared minus
b squared, and you should
easily be able
to recognize it.
You should be able to prove it
to yourself as well that this
is the same thing as a plus
b times a minus b.
Or in this case, z plus
2 times z minus 2.
And that is z minus 2.
So this is interesting.
So I don't see exactly
what we wrote.
I have a minus 8, but we want
a z plus 2 and z minus 2.
But they don't have that.
But what they do have is this--
let me rewrite it.
They don't have any of it, but
maybe they have-- they want
the minus to be multiplied by
one of these other terms. So
what we could do is we could
multiply the minus because
multiplication is associative.
It doesn't matter what
order you do it in.
So we could rewrite this as 8
times z plus 2 times minus 1
times z minus 2.
And then this becomes
8 times z plus 2.
This isn't minus 1, this
is times minus 1.
Times what?
Minus z plus 2.
And now I think that
choice is there.
Right.
So we can rewrite this as 8
times 2 plus z-- I'm just
rearranging it-- times
2 minus z.
And then that is choice B.
And so really, given the choices
they gave us, it
probably would have been faster
to just factor out an 8
from the beginning and
not a positive 8.
And you would have immediately
gotten to 2 plus z
times 2 minus z.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.